shred a man this has gone from bad to
worse
see I told you his pep talks suck forget
that Mikey we've got to figure out a way
to stop him and close that portal or the
city's toast that will be far easier
said than done
turtle observe
dragon his monster they have failed but
I assure you I the portal is now under
my control and in mere moments the
energy it is conducting will be
unleashed
and send a signal to the world that I am
not to be trifled with
very soon I
first
this is it shredder this ends here by
the time we're done with you you're
gonna need a can opener to take your
armor off
you wretched mutants still think you
stand a chance
you are more foolish than even I thought
like you better laughter people actually
wait
just try not to fall off the platform
might eat tonight I died on turtle soup
I will finish what I started all those
years
I'm not in the mood for games
I will put an end to you and that
infernal rat let's go get him guys
everything's upside-down
hold it yourself man
she'll go go
we'll crush you
guys little help
it only hurts when I breathe
and break
can't hold it yourself man
that was close you picked a bad day to
mess with me
here I come
I don't feel so well
celebrate this victory while you can
mutants your imminent destruction awaits
the controls have been disabled
look out you might have a sweet jetpack
like karai
I don't think so parachute nope
good rings guys you know that thing
shredder said about the portal controls
being disabled we probably needed that
still working huh
yep my bed
you
hurry Donnie
yeah what's taking so long the primary
controls are history I'm trying to hack
into the redundant controls but
everything's encrypted I just need a
little more time
dudes what's the only thing better than
finding parachutes let me guess
Pizza Mikey you're a genius no dude come
on Donnie we're getting out of here
I can't I haven't broken the code yet
the risk to civilians is too great if I
don't stop this thing I've got to keep
trying you guys go no way done if you
stay we stay yeah
no brother gets left behind man now I
wish I did find pizza instead
when we are honorbound to do anything
yes
you have saved the city and now we're
coming home
Donny out
do you think
come on let's go I'm thinking it's
officially Pizza time heck to the yeah
finally I could eat a hundred by myself
right now hey do you think bee-bop's
giant money bag is still lying around
Mikey just kidding but you gotta admit
5,000 orders of breadsticks would
totally rule
you
you